mais tu m'as mènerait la jusqu'à jusqu'à
maintenant au local des restos du coeur
de génelard le plus petit du département
les bénévoles ne baisse pas les bras
un camion est arrivé ce matin du dépôt
de montchanin et d'autres doivent
arriver de mâcon charolles et
paray-le-monial pour garnir à nouveau
les étagères
j'ai plus rien n'y avait plus rien j'ai
tous mes apporte quelques voyelles ils
m'ont laissé quelques des salles c'est
tout
je n'ai plus rien plus rien mais c'est
assez consternant d'ailleurs mais mes
produits bébé j'ai pu lire çà c'est
consternant quoi s'attaquer aux restos
du coeur je trouve que c'est navrant on
défend quand même on aide les plus
démunis et voilà démunis compte qu'on
dépouille ans et ça dans la nuit de
jeudi à vendredi dernier des malfaiteurs
se sont emparés de tout le stock soit
800 kg de nourriture ils sont passés
sans forcer par le portail avant de
briser les fenêtres
un geste qui désoriente la présidente
départementale de l'association
quelqu'un qui fait ça on a du mal à
comprendre ses motivations
s'ils ont besoin ils ont juste à venir
demander on donnera ici les vingt
bénévoles sont vraiment très à l'écouté
des gens c'est incompréhensible et puis
bon c'est une grosse complications pour
nous c'est la troisième fois en trois
mois que le local est touchée par des
actes de vandalisme
la présidente réfléchit à mieux protéger
le site il faudra sécuriser les endroits
un peu plus fragilisés sont des portes
en bois ça n'a pas été conçu pour être
un coffre-fort
c'est un centre de distribution mais on
va essayer de faire pour qui n'est pas
qu'ils ne connaissent plus quand même ce
genre de déboires en attendant la chaîne
de solidarité se poursuit
les bénévoles doivent être prêt pour
jeudi prochain où une distribution est
prévue pour 20 familles des environs